[Applaudissements]
jeandel tout
le chamboule-tout salut à tous salut
salut salut qu à ça va mais on salue
notre salut à vous expliquer avec
mercedes s'il te plait merci d'être là à
ce que tu vas donner les chaussettes
tonnes aux habits mercedes merci tu es
gentil vois tu commences à merci allez
on y va sortir des chaussettes cp ce 1 3
au 7 mars à saclay soit 700 ferrand les
arvida mais comme mercedes tu commences
à me courir sur le haricot vert 3 3
piles
vous voyez bien vous allez devoir tout
chambouler le chamboule-tout le
chamboule de ces partis au chamboule
tatupu m'étouffe riad sattouf vous avez
foi vous froide sur 7,7 à attention les
chiens que celui qui fera le meilleur
score points à éliminer une personne qui
rentrera directement chez lui et cette
personne n'entrera en peluche et je dis
bien on peut alors alors ya une peluche
je veux dire les déguisements super
favori c'est quoi les déguisements mon
chéri on a quoi on a mené c'est quoi
c'est quoi ça non ça c'est un ours est
pas très bien y rentrer mais attention
il devra et devra rentrer et un éléphant
mais un éléphant merci merci à ma part
ayant lapin ma mère si mercedes était
sympa par bercy peuvent la merci des
progrès merci martin verser de ce qu'ils
vont chez moi qui prends l'oseille au
niveau haut niveau les allées bondées
partie vous allez y aller vous avez des
trous noirs
et attention on y va pour les trois
premiers vous jouez avec lui chez vous
regardez à votre avis qui va gagner à
chaque tpm paix chamboule tout vous y
allez à mon top géraldine maillet vous
allez être la première attention les
images allaient manita 307,3 ce set la
tension hta 3e set qui a 3 au 7 août une
paire de lunettes je le rappelle on y va
jouera peut être plus alors à quand son
really nord-est
1 2 3 4 5 6 6 il te reste 6 allez c'est
parti
c'est parti madame à laisser partir l
attention alors la dame sur pourra
débattre contention pourrait entrer dans
le cercle est ravi mais ressent chez
mignonne merci maman merci attention
d'autres cercles et où et oui au pérou
et le cerf céleste une source à la merci
c'est parti on y va comprendre et actes
pas dans l'air d'un bordel à queue
sauf qu'à l'heure du boom l'instant vous
attention vous êtes en danger ou mettez
sur le web joue souvent c'est le premier
pour l'instant puisqu'il ne reste que ça
qu'on est parti super des dc je rappelle
qu'on laisse le des arts à distance
fevad
[Applaudissements]
alors est alors oui
je suis le problème je vivais pour
l'astra carrefour benhaim on y va à une
n attendez attendez on y va très compact
qui pompe pour l'instant si vous nous
rejoignez bien sûr c'est le champion
tout dans un astronome rageot des gars à
mickaël youn se mérite qu'on est
mercedes qui mangent de la barbe à papa
tu sais pas regardé un reportage m m tu
peux te mettre la merci mon chéri allez
on y va c'est parfait dégage tu fais moi
dégager la super ça va vous parler
[Applaudissements]
regardez c'est très dur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est pas mal parce que là la lamal et
parce qu'elle a mal au dos pas mal j'ai
mal partout
c'est bon on y va à l'évasion jean louis
caillet et nantes et j'ai omis et tenter
ils restent eux qui restent pas que si
mme kenny est au dessus des coûts qui a
été tout donner et yari mais il en reste
3 attention vous allez désigner celui
qui va rentrer chez lui directement le
dit qu'ils nous frappent à l'émission tu
dois centre a même pas tombé tout seul
moyen à l'aider au total
imerys bernabeu alors les chéris je vous
explique un petit peu histoire dans
manière tout depuis le début le
chamboule-tout celui qui aura fait le
meilleur score on a le droit d'éliminer
une personne qui va rentrer directement
chez lui dans sa baraque qui va laisser
piloter qui valait plus aussi que de
l'accord il faudra pas du tout les murs
du palais yachts et vallées sont aussi
d'accord on est content 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8
9 10 11 peut largement faire une
émission il ya des gens qui font une
émission et qu on va arrêter de se taire
c'est peu pâle et les mais bon merci
[Rires]
elle va être un gros du minnesota battu
matière au ralenti toi il a donné on va
les laisser replacer les trois attention
mettez moi place d'autres gynéco maxime
gainey rmn merci reste une lueur sur une
barbe à papa là ce petit plaisir merci
et c'est parti ça valait chéri on s'en
sort
merci - pour les applaudissent en
rigolant
mais bon c'est pas gai aléatoire selon
nous la jeunesse juste jusqu'à présent
c'est jean michel branquart jean michel
c'est toi qui en tête
hoxhaj en chine jean-michel coince dans
la franchise ligne tu va envoyer chez
lui tôt pour l'instant si c'est si ça
reste valérie damidot j'ai pitié d'elle
valérie valérie valérie elle va se
retrouver à assumer tout est là on chez
elle à noël va faire du stop et crois
pas que tu rentres chez toi comme ça dow
chemical a way elle est imminent à
rentrer alors attention à 60 rappeur ça
c'est parti doc gynéco mon chéri c'est à
toi tu en es ce que je vois à fléron je
pense que là tu n'es pas ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ces deux vidéos qui en tête
attention c'est pas les stats a fait
deux trois quatre
anathema des mines allez on doit placer
celui de raymond pour la star c'est doc
gynéco qui est temps de réfléchir à mon
chéri institut va renvoyer chez eli
d'accord attention cela fait combien
j'ai envie de croire jean mi temps mais
c'est pas cher et il s'est donc je
découvre sur comme geneco lloris qu'une
à plein régime nazi répondent en cela
n'aurait pas non plus oublier foot sur
rené pas d'autre n'est pas dans le cas
d'un cdn gynéco savait gagner et
tentèrent bien qu'apple donc il est con
mon chéri c'est toi qui as gagné tu peux
demander à n'importe qui ici de rentrer
chez lui en costume de lapin tandis que
soit le costume de lapin je le sens bien
je vais te dire ça peut même être mon
nom suivez tu peux non ça peut être
mercedes et qui va faire la mission si
après johnny janish votre mercedes est
jeune ça peut être n'importe qui ici
cette personne va prendre ses cliques et
ses claques il va rentrer chez elle
c'est une suite donc j les coûts est ce
que tu veux que le hasard si longue
phase les choses
le hasard alors je vous faire un jeu le
jeu vous connaissez on va le jouer au
hasard par un gynéco c'est très simple
et chéri sam chit alors signalé
chirurgie chéri les chérissait très
chargé le filet de rinne vous allez tout
tous mettre votre main derrière le dos
on va partir de moi et je vais compter
j'ai compté combien ça fait on va partir
de mois celui qui sera désigné rentrera
chez lui en costume de lapin et fera
directement du stop ici d'accord et il
essaiera trouver quelqu'un qui le ramène
chez lui j'habite à cergy-pontoise mans
et bat habitat charge du 25 août les
jeudis en fait ici c'est toi et ta
chance
attention attention crois pas que l'un
d'eux alors sa 5e plus de 7,7 plus haut
de neuf 9 plus de 11 aux opus 3 14 14 e
+4 18-18 +1 19 21 21 23 23 plus 4 27 27
plus de 4 31 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12
13 14 15 16 17 18 19 20 21 22
24 25 26 27 28 29 30 31 bat décidément
c'est fini benzi vos séries est ce que
tu as des choses à dire à ton public
à demain j'aime beaucoup mes costumes
les mêmes costumes aux séries es et tu
t'es sûr un peu dehors là tu vas essayer
de trouver quelqu'un qui te ramène pour
pire des cas je te ramène moi ça sera
mon chéri